[Music]
5 24 on your wednesday morning you know
officially it hadn't even been a year
but anyone who's driven on charleston
between las vegas boulevard and eastern
recently man it feels like it's been
going on for five years
there have been countless days like this
where you're down to one slow painful
lane and guess what starting at nine
tonight it's going to get worse
the city of las vegas completely
shutting down charleston and eastern for
up to six days scheduled to run until
five monday morning they're putting
those giant concrete storm drain boxes
underground as part of a 51 million
dollar project in coordination with the
regional flood control district if you
don't have to go anywhere near
charleston eastern and fremont through
the weekend
don't
yeah we are suggesting some alternates
that you could try maybe sahara bonanza
or stuart for east west travel las vegas
boulevard or maryland parkway for north
south travel now if you do have to be
there where the closure is a lot of
detour options we've got them in the
online version of this story on our
website when you click traffic then
driving you crazy and hang in there this
project's supposed to run through all of
next year completion maybe january of
2024
buckle up drive carefully please put
down that phone you can join the driving
you crazy conversation at traffic eight
at eightnewsnow.com